now it's my pleasure to introduce ray
lane ray and Stephanie Lane have made
many contributions to Carnegie Mellon
including of course the funding of the
lane Center for computational biology
but also through a great deal of time
and effort and very valuable assistance
so ray has been serving as a trustee for
many years until recently was director
of our capital campaign called inspire
innovation and most recently as accepted
the role as chairman of the board of
trustees for Carnegie Mellon University
so right
Thank You Randy it is a great week for
Pittsburgh and it's a great day for
Carnegie Mellon University and it is a
great great honor for me to stand before
you today and join you for this great
dedication of the gates and Hillman
centers you can imagine the joy of a
person whose father 50 years ago when I
was very very small very young when he
was taking some of these early computer
science courses here at Carnegie Tech
saying son whatever you do stay away
from these computers are much too hard
and my mother would attest that I really
you know doesn't listen very well then
and don't listen very well now this
event is a significant milestone in the
university's history in the history of
computer science recognizing the caliber
of teaching and research work that takes
place here and for many years to come
the widespread and strong support for
this new building from all of you and
especially our lead partners Bill and
Melinda Gates the foundation that they
that they represent and the Henry hell L
Hillman foundation is a testament to
just how important this wonderful new
facility is going to be to innovation
and the economic growth of this region
the United States and the world in
general so what I'd like to do now is if
Jerry Provost mark Hamlet trustee ed
Frank Henry bill and Brandi are already
here I think I got everybody and I'd
like I think we have a cadre of computer
science students that are going to join
us here on the stage for the formal
dedication and ribbon-cutting of the
buildings there they are
now in please join us all please open
thank you now in Carnegie Mellon fashion
we thought would answer colleague in
robotics to help us do the ribbon
cutting so he's going to join us or
she's going to join us I'm not quite
sure from the end of stage which I can't
see so Jerry if you could accept the
scissors from our friend thank the robot
Jerry bill and Henry would like you to
know that we are starting a new
tradition here at Carnegie Mellon these
scissors that you're using today will be
the official ribbon cutting scissors for
all future building openings at the
University and I hope there will be many
generations from now when another
dignitary is ready to cut a ribbon using
these commemorative scissors they will
know that both of you were the first to
use them and my guess is that they will
make that celebration even more
gratifying for them so formally and
officially as chair of the Carnegie
Mellon Board of Trustees I would like to
hereby dedicate the gates center for
computer science and the hillman Center
for future generation technologies today
September 22nd 2009 as an expression of
our special gratitude to the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation and the Henry L
Hillman foundation gentlemen please do
the honors
you